[Musica]
cosa succede nella mia vita quando è
stato esattamente il momento in cui mi
sono trasformato in un bidone della
raccolta differenziata in cui la gente
butta qualsiasi cosa orrida volete
sapere cos'è questo
questa è la rappresentazione della paura
dell'uomo e quella paura dell'ignoto
descritta nei libri di lovecraft e lo
zoom
beh magari non così tanto grave ma ci si
avvicina vi ricordate il video su tiro
sauri quel cartone animato della dingo
pixel doppiato come un film porno
filippino mamma e papà anno nuovo per
dare non se ne fanno più niente di te
ecco questo è il gioco della phoenix
game
pensavate di essere al sicuro vero i
vostri negozi di videogiochi senza
nessuna paura ed invece nei cestoni
delle offerte per mortaccioni senza
soldi
sbucano questi che voglio dire solo la
copertina fa invidia ai disegni dei
bambini che ci sono dal mio dentista
dunque questo e dinosaur adventure il
dinosauri di cui abbiamo parlato prima
ma io domi non è quello i disegni sono
diversi e per forza se avessero ne sono
immagini originali in copertina non se
non sarebbero comprato manco con una
pistola in culo quindi ecco qui piedino
della valle incantata praticamente poi
abbiamo dal mission 3 o come sarebbe
stato chiamato da noi la carica dei 103
ma ti ricordi non quello dove crudelia
de mon assomiglia eva grimaldi e non le
pa grimaldi che si ricordano tutti
quella precede vi starete chiedendo
perché io vi stia facendo vedere dei
videogiochi
basta leggere bollino giallo include
cartone animato sto tenendo in mano il
dvd che include il cartone animato
dinosauri è il videogioco di mino sauri
e che non sono sicuro che sia una cosa
di cui vantarmi ma quello che voglio
vedere all'istante e de tollis room qui
chiamato così ma è conosciuto anche come
toys o toy story ovvio non potevano
lasciare fuori toy story dovevano per
forza rovinarmi infanzia e quando mai
e siccome sono una persona generosa vi
voglio regali
un conato di vomito una delle immagini
che si trova nel trailer di questo
capolavoro e che fece vedere già ai
tempi ti è tutta per voi ma tranquilli
quelle solo marketing il cartone è
completamente diverso però bello il toy
story della lidl è dunque se non vi
siete ancora strappati gli occhi con un
coltello da filettatura diamogli
un'occhiata
madò da quant'è che non la uso la play 2
che tra l'altro devo giocare asta
robaccia con un joystick della sony ci
sono proprio i phone i forni sono povero
a è così e quello schifo che mettono
ovunque nella copertina
sembra una versione aberranti di tombino
e pompadour
manson ieri sul retro è segnata la
lingua italiana ma nel gioco non c'è
cos'era per segnarti che la copertina in
italiano fortunatamente ci sono anche le
versioni dvd di sti cosi quindi ok
questo è il menù da qui possiamo
guardare il film è giocare a quattro
siti incredibili minigiochi e colorare
le immagini un normalissimo memory con
le pere completare un puzzle e mettere
in ordine le immagini
wow vale pienamente i soldi spesi non
vedo l'ora che esca la game of the year
edition con lo sgambetto come statuetta
la cosa più entusiasmante e andare nelle
opzioni dove possiamo abbassare l'audio
del film quello dei giochi e dopo
no non ho capito giusto per curiosità i
giochi degli altri titoli come saranno
ho gli stessi identici giochi ma con
immagini diverse piatto questi via c'è
spazio solo per te ti amo ma passiamo al
piatto forte il cortometraggio animato
il cartone inizia con un font che non
vedeva dai tempi di powerpoint ed il
primissimo sfondo notare la colorazione
fatta probabilmente comprendere gli
scarichi e il tetto spiovente disegnato
con un goniometro per fare le righe
dritte no
bella anche la montagna non colorata o
grandissime aspettative per questo film
mancano solamente due ore sospiro appino
e bambolotto di pezza
oh sì solamente due ore sospiravano
anche gli altri valori non avevo dubbi e
presentiamoli questi giocate balocchi
abbiamo il balocco telefono sai no di
quelli che regalavano la tua sorellina
piccola con luci e suoni poco poco
fastidiosi
[Musica]
il game boy viola perlato con l'erezione
perenne c'era bisogno di metterla
analogico proprio lì il balocco cuscino
che in realtà è no è un cuscino e basta
e grande divertimento per tutte le età
mamme è arrivato il cuscino fate
divertire i vostri bambini con la cosa
più noiosa che avete in casa ma aspetta
questo vuol dire che ho praticamente un
toy sente case non lo sapevo poi c'è uno
dei figli di satana il pagliaccio
demoniaca che esce dalla scatola
probabilmente quella che il razer lo
skateboard con tanto di cappello e
occhiali da sole come i bambini figli
degli anni 90 ed il nostro protagonista
il bambolotto di pezza fatto con scarti
di persone morte e vomito di nome pilo
pilo avrebbero voluto chiamarlo
gianvincenzo però nome sulla scatola non
ci stava e quindi come avrete notato la
storia raccontata tutta da una
narratrice esterna che darà voce a tutti
quanti che cosa avete detto is il
telefono che si chiamava pronto lui era
un po duro d'orecchi
per questo bisognava ripetere le cose
due volte sta per arrivare la notte di
natale e i balocchi hanno paura che
possano venir rimpiazzati da giocatori
nuovi e la notte di natale verrà un
giocattolo nuovo da noi spiega ha
pazientemente coccolino si è poi il
bambino giocherà solamente con i suoi
giocattoli nuovi e 9 fischietto cialis
online per l'amor di dio qualcuno regali
delle mutande agli boy che ormai fa
facendo nell'incontro col pene se ci
penso bene non credo proprio che lui
possa voler bene al nuovo giocattolo
piuttosto che a me di questo ne è
convinto solo tu non ti guarderà più e
la sua mamma ne approfitterà ta
accertarti via vuole farlo già da molto
tempo tu sei sporco e poco igienico ha
ragione il clown tu sei pericoloso per
la salute del bambino
a differenza del rastrello e della palla
appoggiata al muro e sono proprio
approvati dalla pec per erg per farci
giocare i bambini che voglio dire
probabilmente si diverte di più con
quelli che non con un cazzo di cuscino
però ed arriva il momento della consegna
dei regali
[Musica]
non c'è né basta buttate via tutti i
vostri dvd arrivati questo è il futuro
sembra quasi la vita vera ma apriamo
questo regalo natalizio e scopriamo il
nuovo balocco il bambino apri proprio
quel regalo per ultimo c'era dentro una
bambola bebè nuova di zecca
caro babbo natale
non so da quale girone infernale uscito
quell'aborto ma ti prego
chiudi la tua fabbrica di giocattoli e
dati fuoco
tanti auguri di ottobre
non solo il brutto come la peste nera ma
è anche gravemente malato a giudicare
dal rigurgito radiativo sul petto c'è
anche i giocatori concordato con me ecco
che cosa è veramente brutto esclamò
roller non potrà certamente voler bene a
quella bambola si rallegrò pino e
sospirò alleggerito in quel momento il
nuovo giocattolo sesia frignare ma ma
scusa hanno regalato un bambolotto che
piange ad un ragazzino vuoi vedere che
babbo natale ha sbagliato indirizzo
che cazzo è sta roba papa questo è il
nome del bamboccione inizio a devastare
le viti di tutti smettila subito di
provocarci altrimenti io sono un bebè e
il bebè possono fare tutto quello che
vogliono
ma incredibilmente al ragazzino sto coso
piace che cosa ti aveva detto ris e
tante al team fante il ragazzino che al
fisico di un 35enne lampadato io fossi
intendono toccherei senza prima
stabilizzarlo ma comunque pino è quello
più toccato da questa storia che inizia
per piangere bianchi e pianista piange
piangere tra le braccia di cuscino gli
altri giocattoli cercano di aiutarlo
come possono
ci buttiamo sulla sua testa tutti
insieme se questo non è abbastanza io
l'ho schiaccerà aggiunsero aler potrai
tra iarla pezzi con la mia molla
sogghigno entusiasta jumping jack oppure
lo strozziamo con il filo del mio
telefono io gli studi della rai disse
lever fest si è invece gli squartini
sogni disse freddi e invece di buttare
tutto in discarica disse franco quello
della raccolta differenziata che ha
capito quanto siamo fottuti c'erano
tutti quanti ma che cazzo di psicopatici
remo lista camera disperato pino scappa
dalla finestra per andare via per sempre
viaggiando avvolto dalla notte in una
città dalle dubbie linee dovrà
affrontare dei pericoli spaventosi
[Musica]
scivola e cade sul naso
no è no io lo so che è un cartone per
bambini questo ma questo è la
rappresentazione visiva di tutto ciò che
c'è di sbagliato nel mondo ma che idea
del cazzo e animare i bidoni in quel
modo lì il lampione si piegò curioso per
vedere quello che stava succedendo
io non ho più un anima questa sequenza
di abomini mi ha reso un uomo vuoto
privo di sentimenti ed identità io in
realtà non porto i pantaloni non mi
chiamo neanche io toby il mio nome
monica
e solo un disegno bello ciao benvenuto
nel mio canale di recensioni di sedie
che successo stampa piccoletto veloce
prima che i ratti di mordano esclamò lo
stacco nel nulla è un tocco di classe
dove dell'alpino si riprese dalla
spaventa e scappo via a gambe levate
funge fugge correva mentre i suoi amici
non lo trovano uno si perse chissà dove
ne rimasero solo 99 piccoli balocchi che
adesso stai zitto piccolo rompiscatole
bravo cuscino vending ovation bravo e
fammi conto che i cuscini si arrabbiano
molto raramente
e i cuscini si arrabbiano molto
raramente tutti tranne pump decidono di
andare a cercare i pilot chiedendo prima
i bidoni pino pino si chiama così risero
i bidoni della spazzatura
se non fossi già accaduto una volta
questa notte per le risate cadrai adesso
se vuoi ci penso io guarda non c'ho
problemi persino i topi obesi non hanno
idea di dove sia pilot che in realtà sia
addormentato nella discarica o quale
ironia di luogo viene risvegli
un nano da giardino con la pipa volle
non dovete farvi domanda è ovvio che
forse è un personaggio più interessante
del previsto posso immaginarmi che cosa
ti è successo sei stato gettato via dal
tuo proprietario e ora non sai dove
andare e la rappresentazione di babbo
natale nella storia o forse sto leggendo
io troppo a fondo
fatto sta che gli amici non riescono a
trovarlo fino a quando a sta scadendo il
tempo del cortometraggio un altro tabù
bene su completamente a caso li aiuta
mandandoli nella direzione giusta
ha ragione riesco a sentirlo vino dalla
gioia di aver ritrovato pino roller
saltava per aria tutti si rotolarono per
terra dalla felicità sono felice anche
io
e finalmente possono tornare tutti a
casa insieme contenti e via il gatto
random che non si è mai visto prima in
tutto il cartone tra 3 2 1 vai felice
prese pino fra le braccia ma cambia mai
animazione per mio
alla fine il messaggio è chiaro e
diretto senza odio si riesce a vivere in
armonia
tutti insieme devo accettare il fatto
che lui voglia bene anche a qualcun
altro
aggiunse guarda panda e maligno il
prossimo anno verrà ancora natale e
arriverà un giocattolo nuovo vedrai
[Musica]
con quale velata minaccia di morte però
me lo stai dicendo
vedrai ecco questa angoscia
questo era de tollis room un pasticcio
di disegni storti storia plagiata
animazioni inesistenti e morali ignobile
a quanto pare allora perché ho voluto
fare proprio questo perché questo è un
regalo vostro così come moltissime altre
cose nel corso degli anni per ricordarci
che questa cazzo di communion ippiche
stop da molto tempo dei grandi
risultando un po troppo spesso alla fine
non è così merda ma se qualcuno si
lamenta nella community è perché ci
tiene vorrebbe vederla in modo diverso
semplicemente verso la fine di questo
mese il canale compila otto anni 8 e per
quanto tante cose siano cambiate in
peggio una non è mai cambiata noi
funzioniamo soprattutto grazie al vostro
supporto che sembra quasi una di quelle
pubblicità per il cancro al seno però
niente ogni tanto è giusto ricordarsene
tutto qui ma basta co ste robe
grazie mille per aver seguito il video
ci vediamo ad una prossima recensione di
serie ciao